let's tell each other the truth here  though I mean really you want to talk  truth I actually wants us asked to  describe to a group of PNG women from  around the world what it's like to be  gay what the experience is like  and the way I described it was it is to  never know when you're going to be  hunted if you're in the closet you can't  be bringing all your energy to the  workplace because you're holding some of  that energy to protect your own identity  your own sense of safety I started  looking for my community for LGBTQ  people in PNG who I could relate to we  should feel free to associate as a group  of gay and lesbian employees we just  want to be recognized for who we are  it was the importance of recognizing a  person's full life and the importance of  their having a choice and what that life  would be and I wanted to create the  world I want to live in if you're being  discriminated against you have to fight  back  [Music]